bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat il faudra donc attendre
le 20 novembre prochain pour savoir si
le sénat donne son feu vert à la
proposition de loi qui fait du 19 mars
date anniversaire du cessez-le-feu en
algérie en 1962 la journée commémorative
de souvenir des victimes de la guerre
d'algérie mais aussi des combats qui ont
eu lieu à la même époque en tunisie et
au maroc
la séance a été interrompue les
sénateurs n'ont donc pas pu débattre des
articles de cette proposition de loin
qui je vous le rappelle a été votée il
ya dix ans par l'assemblée nationale
c'était en 2002 alors il hier à
l'ouverture de la séance le kader arif
le ministre en charge des anciens
combattants a expliqué qu'elle s'en
remettait à la sagesse du parlement
l'exécutif ne souhaite donc pas
interférer ni sont gérés dans cette
proposition de loi dont l'inscription à
l'ordre du jour du sénat a relancé le
débat sur la dette à laquelle il fallait
commémorer la fin de la guerre d'algérie
tout de suite donc direction l'hémicycle
pour revoir la discussion générale de ce
texte bonne matinée à tous l'ordre du
jour appelle la discussion de la
proposition de loi adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale relative à la
reconnaissance du 19 mars comme journée
nationale du souvenir et de
recueillement à la mémoire des victimes
civiles et militaires de la guerre
d'algérie et des combats en tunisie au
maroc dans la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur kader arif
ministre chargé des anciens combattants
et la parole sous ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs
le sénat examine aujourd'hui une
proposition de loi initialement adopté
par l'assemblée nationale et visant à
reconnaître la date du 19 mars comme
journée nationale du souvenir et du
recueillement en mémoire des victimes
civiles et militaires de la guerre
d'algérie et des combats en tunisie au
maroc travail de mémoire est une
nécessité vous le savez bien plus encore
pour moi est une exigence une
responsabilité en matière de cohésion du
pays
c'est en particulier le cas pour ce qui
concerne les drames d'afrique du nord
qui de par leur proximité temporelle
sans toque 500 sont encore autant de
réminiscences douloureuse et de plaies
ouvertes qu'il incombe aujourd'hui à la
nation d'apaiser et progressivement
calmement collectivement de cicatriser
cette démarche est une des priorités du
gouvernement
elle est à la base du sentiment
d'appartenance de tous les français à la
communauté nationale en participant à la
connaissance et à la compréhension de
leur propre histoire
elle est la source leur citoyenneté et
de leur sentiment d'appartenance la
république que les moments combatif
doivent contribuer à entretenir via
l'indispensable ritualisation d'un passé
commun la représentation nationale a
pris l'initiative d'examiner de débattre
des termes cette mutualisation afin de
déterminer de quelle manière les
français nos concitoyens seront invités
à se souvenir
la question est naturellement complexe
elle impose de chacun qui fasse un pas
un pas vers l'avant et non pas un pas
sur le côté afin d'écouter de chercher à
comprendre les attentes les
préoccupations de toute la diversité du
monde combattant et civils je pense
naturellement nous appelés du contingent
qui avait accueilli avec soulagement la
fin officielle des hostilités
je pense war tiff qui ont cru à la
france qui sont battus pour elle et qui
pour nombre d'entre eux ont payé un
lourd tribut de leur engagement
je n'oublie pas des civils qui sont
aussi des victimes des périodes sombres
de fin de conflit
cette situation fondamentalement
sensible appel au dialogue ouvert et
respectueux entre les représentants de
la nation
un dialogue qui permette de dépasser les
oppositions stériles et de tourner
définitivement la page des querelles
politiques internes tout
particulièrement autour de la guerre
d'algérie il en va de la capacité notre
pays à intégrer le souvenir douloureux
de ces conflits en afrique du nord dans
le calendrier comme natif du 21e siècle
afin que les français puissent regarder
leur passé en face sa culpabilité ni
autre forme de repentance dans le
respect de toutes les victimes et qu'il
puisse faire cette mémoire collective
une pierre angulaire de leur histoire
indispensable pour construire ensemble
un avenir commun je sais je sais la
représentation nationale parfaitement
consciente de ces enjeux et de la
responsabilité qui est la sienne
votre honorable chambre est par essence
celle de la réflexion discernement et de
la mesure
elle est celle de la pondération et de
la sagesse sagesse à laquelle je me
remets aujourd'hui dans le plein respect
des prérogatives du parlement
car c'est au parlement qu'il aime comme
déterminer l'issue d'un processus
législatif qu'il a lui même initié et ce
sans aucune ingérence ou interférence de
la part de l'exécutif
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à monsieur alain néri rapporteur de
la commission des affaires sociales
ce président messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices faire collègues nous avons
aujourd'hui à débattre nous allons
débattre de la reconnaissance officielle
de la guerre d'algérie par la nation une
proposition de loi était adopté le 22
janvier 2002 par l'assemblée nationale
et aujourd'hui nous poursuivons ce long
cheminement
il y à 50 ans c'est tel cessez-le-feu en
algérie le cessez-le-feu en algérie
au terme de longues souffrances et
malheureusement je ne fus pas le terme
de toutes les souffrances la guerre
d'algérie n'est pas fini le 19 mars
le 19 mars c'est le cessez le feu et en
aucun cas ce cessez le feu
né à confondre avec la fin de la guerre
d'algérie aujourd'hui cinquante ans
après il est urgent de rendre hommage et
de rendre honneur et dignité à la
troisième génération du feu
cette génération du feu qui partit en
algérie parfois sans comprendre tous les
objectifs parfois sans les partager tous
et qui a répandu avec abnégation et
courage à l'appel de la nation
cette troisième génération du feu
n'oublions pas qu'elle est celle des
enfants de la guerre 39 45
ceux qui avaient déjà souffert de
l'occupation de ces privations
matérielles mais surtout de ses
privatisations morale et affective
pour beaucoup il ne connut en leur père
qu'à cinq ans lorsqu'il rentrait de
captivité ou parfois
il ne l'est connurent pas d'autre ne
connurent pas leur mère parce qu'elles
sont victimes de la déportation et 10
ans après le retour des terres ou le non
retour des pères et des mères il partait
en algérie mettez vous à la place aussi
des familles et en particulier des mères
qui après avoir vu partir leur époux en
39 45
voyez partir leur fils un algérie
douloureuse épreuve épreuve d'autant
plus douloureuse que pendant longtemps
la france n'a pas osé reconnaître qu en
algérie
c'était bien la guerre hypocritement
abusivement et abusivement au sens
premier du terme en abuser les
françaises et les français en leur dise
harnes algérie ce sont des événements
ce sont de la pacification
ce sont du maintien de l'ordre
et bien quand il ya 38 morts lors que
l'armée française est engagée avec ses
trois armes l'armée de terre l'armée de
l'air et la marine
lorsque cinq cent mille soldats français
sont mobilisés sur le sol algérien
lorsque plus de deux millions de jeunes
français ont participé à la guerre
d'algérie il nous paraissait calme cruel
ne pas reconnaître la guerre d'algérie
il a fallu atteindre 37 ans après le
cessez le feu
il a fallu attendre 1999 pour qu'une
proposition de loi socialiste que ce
conte et dia j'en étais rapporteur
permettent de reconnaître enfin qu en
algérie c'était la guerre d'ailleurs
comment répliquer opus il en être
autrement quand
on parler d'événement et pourtant on
reconnaissait la qualité de combattant
pour une action de fred combat si les
actions de feu de combat s'il ya des
morts
c'est bien qu'il y avait guère eh bien
je crois que aujourd'hui plus personne
ne peut nier qu'un algérie c'était la
guerre
et cette guerre d'algérie qui reste elle
trop longtemps une guerre sans nom ne
doit pas rester une guerre sans date
historique et symbolique de
reconnaissance et de recueillement pour
toutes les victimes de cette guerre
car si ce fut le cessez-le-feu
ce ne fut pas la fin des souffrances
avant le 19 mars les appelait les
rappeler les 1004 carrières et leurs
familles ont souffert de la séparation
de la peur des violences des deuils
après le 19 mars d'autres souffrances
accélérèrent pour les rapatrier qu'on
appelait aussi les pieds-noirs obligés
de quitter leur terre natale et leurs
racines et puis les harkis qui avaient
placé leur confiance dans la france qui
avait cru à la parole de la france et
qui furent odieusement et honteusement
désarmés et abandonnés sur ordre du
gouvernement de l'époque et ceux qui
furent accueillis en france le doivent
au courage d'officiers qui désobéir aux
ordres et rapatriaient leurs harkat et
pourtant lorsqu'ils arrivèrent en france
ce ne fut pas un accueil chaleureux pour
eux non plus ils furent parqués dans des
camps et ça ne durera pas quelques mois
ça durera plusieurs années
j'ai souvenance d'avoir visité dans les
années 79 80
mas thibert là où étaient accueillis
dans des conditions déplorables
larcat du bachaga boualem et on n'avait
pas aucune raison d'être fiers des
conditions d'accueil
aujourd'hui tous ont souffert de la
guerre et nous ne devons pas here are
cheese et les souffrances les
souffrances des uns et des autres pour
être reconnue à égalité par la nation
qui doit se réconcilier avec son
histoire et c'est pourquoi nous ne
pouvons nous satisfaire d'une date qui
ne soit pas une date historique et
symbolique parce que la guerre d'algérie
comme les deux conflits mondiaux
appartiennent à notre histoire est la
troisième génération du feu mérite une
date historique et symbolique comme les
deux générations précédentes
le 11 novembre c'est l'armistice
c'est pas la fin de la guerre 14 18 elle
s'est poursuivie en orient 39 45
le 8 mai c'est pas la fin de la guerre
c'est la capitulation nazie et cette
capitulation nazie
c'est un moment historique que personne
ne pourra effacer de nos mémoires et
qu'on ne doit pas effacer la mémoire et
qu'on doit continuer à faire partager
aux générations futures
de la même façon l'armistice de 14-18
représente une spécificité qui fait
partie de notre histoire et c'est pour
ça qu'on ne peut accepter non plus ce
que certains voudraient nous faire
excusez moi du terme avalé un mémorial
des noms il faut que chaque génération
du feu et sa date historique et
spécifiques
et pour la troisième génération du feu
c'est le 19 mars date du cessez-le-feu
et non pas date de la fin des combats
je dirais que cette troisième génération
du feu el merrikh l'hommage de la nation
le recueillement en souvenir de toutes
les souffrances mais le mairie que si un
deuxième titre parce que s'ils
partageaient pas toujours les objectifs
ils sont allés en algérie à l'appel de
la nation et ils ont répandu aussi une
deuxième fois à l'appel de la nation
lorsqu'ils ont sauvé la république en
s'opposant putsch des généraux d'alger
est bien pour toutes ces raisons la
nation value ni rassembler leurs douars
hommage et reconnaissance
c'est ce que nous allons faire
aujourd'hui en faisant que unis
rassembler la france dans l'apaisement
rendent hommage à tous ceux qui ont
souffert des cruautés de la guerre des
silences des peurs des deuils chers
collègues je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
france a l'occasion de se réconcilier
avec son histoire
nous devons gravé dans le marbre de la
loi les souffrances qui sont gravées
dans le coeur et dans la chair de tous
les français
parce que nous sommes ici pour rappeler
ce qu'est la république et la démocratie
et ça on aura notre assemblée de voter
cette loi qui permettra effectivement
que la troisième génération du feu soit
reconnu à égalité avec ses deux
précédentes pour avoir défendu et
soutenu la république la démocratie et
la paix
merci mon cher collègue dans la suite de
la discussion générale la parole est un
monsieur guy fischer le seul président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
enfin enfin en cette année symbolique du
50e anniversaire du cessez-le-feu en
algérie
nous sommes sur le point de voir aboutir
une très ancienne exigences de la
majorité de la troisième génération du
feu la reconnaissance de la date du 19
mars comme journée nationale du souvenir
et du recueillement à la mémoire des
victimes civiles et militaires de la
guerre d'algérie et des combats en
tunisie et au maroc
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
est issu des travaux de l'assemblée
nationale du 22 janvier 2002 résultant
de plusieurs propositions de lois dont
celle de mes amis alain bocquet et à la
mairie au sénat également j'avais au nom
du groupe communiste républicain citoyen
à de nombreuses reprises déposé des
propositions de loi en ce sens pourquoi
ai je l'impression de vivre un moment
exceptionnel historique emblématique
parce que nous avons tant attendu ce
rétablissement de la vérité historique
il aura déjà fallu attendre longtemps
la reconnaissance de l'état de guerre
par la loi du 18 octobre 1999
c'était un premier pas que ne pouvait
que prolonger un acte législatif donnant
enfin à tous une date soldats du
contingent militaire
artix rapatrier population civile
algérienne et française bien sûr une
date qui est son sens non seulement
favorite mais historique pour se
recueillir revenir sur des événements
traumatisants avec l'espoir de vrai à un
apaisement des relations entre les deux
rives de la méditerranée
pourquoi tout ce temps perdu
cette question nous mène au coeur de la
relation très complexes qu'entretiennent
la france et l'algérie fait d'ombré de
lumière qui éclaire de grands historiens
tels que benjamin stora
sylvie thénault et que met en scène des
écrivains tels que mathieu belezi qui
après le grand albert camus et bien
d'autres dépeint dans ses romans
un pays de soleil et de silence et
entonnent le chant funèbre d'une terre
meurtrie je me souviens d'avoir organisé
ici même au sénat en 2010 un colloque
intitulé 1940 1962 les troubles de la
mémoire française avec d'éminents
historiens nous avions pu confronter ce
qu entretiennent les mémoires
collectives des individus et des nations
entre elles leurs liens souvent faussée
avec les faits historiques
nous sommes ici je pense précisément au
coeur d'un sujet qui donne matière à
conflit entre histoire et mémoire
la proposition de loi que nous vous
proposons d'adopter ne constitue en rien
un prêt-à-penser un dingue une
instrumentalisation de l'histoire
l'automne
l'absurde l'ofs ans à l'histoire c'est l
invention de la date du 5 décembre
tout au contraire ici il s'agit
j'y crois profondément dans l'essai
l'histoire s'écrire et la mémoire ce
livre et se penser s'assimiler sur la
base d'une date qui ait du sens et qui
ne peut être que celle de l'anniversaire
du cessez le feu
le lendemain des accords d'evian c'est à
dire le 19 mars 62 comme il en va pour
tous les autres conflits du 20e siècle
la meilleure légitimité de cette date
résident souvenons nous dans
l'approbation des accords d'evian du 18
mars 62 2 est du cessez le feu du matin
du 19 mars par 90 8% des votants lors du
référendum du 8 avril
certes des hommes et des femmes sont
encore tombés des deux côtés après cette
date
c'est la réalité certes le drame des
rapatriés dont j'en ai accueilli des
milliers dans le grand ensemble des
minguettes à vénissieux et bien le drame
des rapatriés doit rester dans la
mémoire collectif et l'abandon des
harkis ne doivent jamais être oubliée
et là aussi à vénissieux nous avons
construit des résidences pour les api
pour qu'il soit traité dignement
même si cette tragédie ne nous fait pas
au nord mais comme l'armistice de la
grande guerre le 11 novembre 1918 et la
capitulation sans condition d armée
nazie le 8 mai 1945 le 19 mars est une
date clé un point d'appui pour la
mémoire comme pour l'histoire avec cette
reconnaissance
j'ai bon espoir que nous mettions enfin
un terme à une triste et stérile
polémique
replaçons lucidement les idées à leur
juste place
qui oserait aujourd'hui remettent en
question le 11 novembre et le 8 mai sous
le prétexte que des belligérants des
civils
perdirent hélas la vie après ces dates
personnes six à avoir la douleur des
mères des sorts des épouses en fuite
elles pourront au moins pour autant
moins respectée certainement pas n
oublions jamais que ce sont les non dits
le silence
pis encore le déni le révisionniste et
la censure qui cristallise ressentiment
haine qui prive les protagonisme d'un
deuil nécessaires à la reconstruction
a contrario comme le disait fort
justement mardi dernier notre collègue
david assouline la vérité apaise je ne
voudrais pas répéter mes propos de mardi
dernier au sujet de l'autre proposition
de résolution adoptée sur la
reconnaissance des massacres du 17
octobre 61
toutefois le parallélisme de ces deux
débats m'impose de soulever à nouveau
monsieur le ministre je me permets de le
faire ici publiquement une contradiction
de taille dans l'attitude du
gouvernement d'un côté faire un pas vers
dans la reconnaissance des exactions de
l'état français colonialiste reconnaître
une date sur laquelle les précédents
gouvernements ont préféré le déni et
puis d'un autre côté et là je m'adresse
solennellement aux nom de mon groupe au
nom de la présidente eliane assassi et
bien d'un autre côté mettre à l'honneur
le tristement célèbre général bigeard
tortionnaires du sinistre mémoire en
algérie comme en inde aussi monsieur le
ministre des relations avec le parlement
est bien le ministre des relations avec
le parlement ne m'a pas répondu mardi
dernier mais vous me connaissez je
poserai la question jusqu'à ce que je
sois satisfait de la réponse car le
sujet est d'importance
soit nous avons une volonté de mettre à
plat globalement les conséquences de
notre politique coloniale pour mieux
réconcilier nos deux peuples soit nous
demeurons
un pied dans le déni inclus dans une
trop timides tentatives de nous
affranchir de 50 ans de silence coupable
cette attitude est je leur répète
intenable le courage de commande d'aller
jusqu'au bout de la démarche d'affronter
des pages qui comptent parmi les moins
glorieuses de notre histoire
je voudrais conclure en vous
interrogeant monsieur le ministre sur la
politique de mémoire qu'entend mener
notre nouveau gouvernement
je souhaite instamment que soient levées
toutes les ambiguïtés relative à
l'instauration d'une date unique
je pense notamment à ce que j'appelle le
dernier mauvais coups de l'ancien
gouvernement la loi du livre du 28
février 2012 faisant de la date du 11
novembre une date d'hommage à tous les
morts pour la france y compris en opex
n'est pas innocente
avez vous la volonté de l'approcher
la mémoire n'est pas uniforme nous
sommes en plein dans ce débat et
l'enseignement de l'histoire se doit de
faire place à toutes les grandes
périodes qui ont marqué notre nation
pour ce faire les programmes
d'enseignement et manuels scolaires ne
devrait-il pas refaire une plus large
place à un enseignement vivant de
l'histoire de tous les conflits dans
lesquels notre peuple nos voisins
européens comme nos anciennes colonies
et protectorats surtt engagé une refonte
ambitieuse et concertée de centre
anciennement ne ferait elle pas un gage
de mémoire partagée de relations
internationales reconstruite par la mise
au jour des pans d'une histoire de
n'assumer optimiste de nature monsieur
le ministre
j'espère que notre nation sera prendre
toute sa place dans des lendemains qui
nous appartient de modeler ensemble
quelles belles perspectives s'offrent à
nous quels défis à relever notamment
pour vous ancien combattant qui nous
écoutent et dans les tribunes
protagonistes d'une guerre longtemps
sans nom et sans vainqueur peut-être
cette sorte de reconstruction
finira-t-elle par a quitté ce lourd
tribut que vous avez porté pendant cinq
décennies
c'est en tout cas mon souhait le plus
cher et c'est l'espoir que je forme pour
le mieux vivre ensemble des générations
futures
merci merci chers collègues discussion
générale la parole est à monsieur hervé
marseille
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues le constat est grave
urgence pressante
notre déficit public est abyssal et
représente plus de 90 pensions du pib le
chômage a dépassé la barre des 3
millions
la part de marché à l'exportation de la
france diminuent chaque jour ça ne vous
plaît pas mais je vais continuer et
l'écart de compétitivité avec
l'allemagne ne cessent de se creuser
l'urgence est clair le diagnostic est
partagé
or depuis le 3 juillet dernier que se
passe-t-il c'est bien simple votre
majorité a eu comme principe moteur de
déconstruire ce qui allait dans le bon
sens l'exonération des charges sur les
heures supplémentaires
l'intéressement des salariés aux
bénéfices de leur entreprise
la majoration des droits à construire on
vous reconnaîtra le mérite d'avoir fait
voter le traité européen négocié par le
président précédent président de la
république et d' avoir pallié à
l'abrogation du dispositif sur le
harcèlement sexuel
en réalité depuis juillet vous l'avais
proposé que deux textes majeurs l'un sur
le logement
entièrement censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel hier soir et le second
intitulé emplois d'avenir
la france attend des réformes monsieur
le ministre les entreprises ont besoin
de plus de compétitivité
les français recherchent des emplois dès
lors quoi de mieux que de botter en
touche
une fois encore votre gouvernement est à
contretemps
plutôt que de saisir des enjeux
fondamentaux qui permettrait au français
d'entrevoir des jours meilleurs vous
nous proposer d'étudier un texte exhumé
de l'assemblée nationale est votée il ya
plus de dix ans texte qui est une pure
et simple abrogation du décret du 26
septembre 2003 qui avait fait du 5
décembre
la journée nationale d'hommage aux morts
pour la france pendant la guerre
d'algérie et les combats du maroc et de
la tunisie décret qui avait été pris
après un processus consultatif mené par
un historien jean favier bref une
procédure proche d'eux
la méthode vanté par monsieur le premier
ministre quelle urgence dès lors il y
avait et il a mobilisé le parlement pour
consacrer une nouvelle date de
commémoration une date qui divise
ces textes ne sont pas identiques dans
leur forme l'un et réglementaires
l'autre législatif ceci n'est pas sans
conséquence alors même que l'article 34
de la constitution fixe le pouvoir du
parlement en ne nous permettant pas de
légiférer en la matière ou souhaité
fixer de manière législatives une date
de commémoration
il ya un précédent je vous invite à vous
intéresser au sort qui avait été réservé
à la loi du 23 février 2005 portant
reconnaissance de la nation et
contribution nationale en faveur des
français rapatriés qui disposait à
l'alinéa 2 de son article 4 que la
colonisation avait qu un rôle positif le
gouvernement en vertu de l'article 2 de
l'article 37 de la constitution avait
saisi le conseil constitutionnel qui
avait déclaré cette disposition comme
étant du domaine réglementaire c'est la
preuve qu'en matière mémorielle le
parlement n'est peut-être pas tout à
fait dans son rôle surtout par la loi
d'une proposition de loi
restons dans notre fonction soyons
cohérents son pote m'étonnais de la
contradiction qui existe entre votre
proposition est le fait qu'en janvier
dernier alors que nous débattions du
texte sur la pénalisation de la négation
des génocides reconnu par la loi
le président fleurs s'opposer
vigoureusement aux textes mémorial en
citant le doyen vedel robert badinter et
d'autres éminents professeurs
d'université en nous expliquant ici même
que ces textes n'étaient pas du domaine
de la loi et qu'il convenait de laisser
les historiens réaliser leurs recherches
dans la sérénité
pour paraphraser le président sueur jour
et rappelé ses propos quel est notre
légitimité à nous législateurs pour dire
ce qu'est l'histoire
en résumé robert badinter rappeler que
parlement n'était pas un tribunal et
pierre nora qu'il ne revenait pas au
législateur de faire l'histoire
alors mes chers collègues si vous
adoptez ce texte ne dit plus par exemple
à la communauté arménienne qui attend un
texte de reconnaissance promu au
demeurant par le président allemande que
cette reconnaissance n'est pas du
domaine de la loi
seconde contradiction monsieur le
rapporteur au cours de l'année 2004
vous l'avez rappelé le groupe socialiste
de l'assemblée nationale dont vous étiez
membre comme françois hollande et jean
marc ayrault déposé une proposition de
résolution vous l'avez rappelé tendant à
créer une commission d' enquête sur les
responsabilités dans le massacre de
nombreuses victimes civiles
rapatriés harkis après la date
officielle du cessez-le-feu de la guerre
en algérie
à cette occasion vous souhaitiez que ce
soit notamment identifier les
responsabilités dans les massacres de la
fusillade de la rue d'isly 26 mars 62 ou
encore de la journée du 5 juillet 62 à
oran autrement dit monsieur le
rapporteur vous n'ignorez pas que ces
événements les vous voulez aujourd'hui
en faisant du 19 mars une date de
commémoration rayer d'un trait de plume
les conséquences des massacres
intervenus par ailleurs la commission en
refusant votre proposition vous rappeler
que langoureusement vous rappeler que
l'encouragement du travail historiques
devaient être préféré à la création
d'une commission denquête troisième
contradiction nous avons étendu en début
d'année l'application de l'article 30 de
la loi du 29 juillet 80 sur la liberté
de la presse aux formations supplétives
des forces armées le droit en vigueur et
en particulier l'article 5 de la loi de
2005 ne trouvez pas d'application pour
des raisons purement juridique dès lors
nous avons réparer cette injustice en
permettant aux harkis d'être protégé
contre ses injures et ses dix fermes à
sion nous avons élargi ce dispositif
protecteur applicables aux harkis et
aujourd'hui ce texte quant à les
humilier en fixant une date de
commémoration de la fin du conflit
algérien préalable aux massacres qu'ils
ont subies en particulier le 5 juillet
1962 à oran
vous le savez alors même que les accords
d'eau d'evian prévoyant un cessez le feu
dès le 19 mars
et vous l'avez rappelé de nombreuses
exactions ont perduré faire de cette
date une journée de commémoration
reviendrait en quelque sorte à nier
l'existence de ces drames qui ont suivi
et qui ont fait de très nombreuses
victimes
le 19 mars 1962 la france a abandonné
dès arty au début de l'année 2012
le parlement français a souhaité
compléter son dispositif protecteur à
l'égard des français rapatriés
j'avais rappelé en sciences à cette
occasion nous savons tous à quel point
il peut être délicat pour une nation de
regarder son passé sans fard pendant
trop longtemps la question de la
reconnaissance de l'engagement des arts
qui a été éludée ont retardé
laissant dans l'incompréhension ceux là
même qui ont fait le choix de la france
lors de l'un des épisodes les plus
douloureux de notre histoire récente
cette injustice a été lentement réparé
par un processus législatif qui se sera
déroulé pendant près de dix ans entre la
loi du 11 juin 94 qui a été la première
exprimé la reconnaissance de la france
ouart qui est celle de 2005 qui a
cherché à protéger les rapatrier leurs
descendants contre les invectives
charriées par un passé encore mal
cicatrisées
mes chers collègues ne faisons pas
machine arrière n'oublions pas les
tragédies qui se sont déroulés après la
mi mars 62 les commémorations doivent
nous rassemble et ne doivent pas nous
diviser sur un si grand temps de
reprendre l'intégralité des propositions
faites à l'automne 2008 par l'historien
andré kaspi le rapport qu'il avait remis
au président de la république propose
est purement et simplement de retirer
trois dates pour les commémorations le 8
mai 14 juillet le 11 novembre
trois dates qui résonnent dans la
conscience de tous les citoyens français
seule la date du 11 novembre a fait
l'objet d'un approfondissement en ce
sens à destination du souvenir de tous
les morts pour la france
faisons donc dû me met par exemple la
célébration de la paix de la
commémoration des victimes militaires et
civiles de toutes les guerres passées
autre piste à suivre celle de notre
collègue yves pozzo di borgo qui a
rappelé lors de l'examen de la
résolution relative au 17 octobre 61
noeuds que les communistes au lancement
d'une vaste concertation sujet des
commémorations relative à la blessure
algérienne notamment en association avec
l'algérie alors mes chers collègues à
l'évidence le 19 mars
ce n'est pas une date qui rassemble
c'est une date qui divise faire de cette
date une commémoration officielle va
cristalliser cette division sur ces
sujets il faut de la sérénité et ce
texte ne va pas dans ce sens jusqu'à
présent il y avait ceux qui commémorait
le 5 décembre ce qui commémorait le 19
mars
ils continueront à le faire ils
continueront à le faire
la seule différence c'est que le préfet
sera le 19 mars devant les monuments il
ne sera plus là bas le 5 décembre
c'est pour cela mes chers collègues je
ne voterai pas ce texte comme les
membres de mon groupe je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue dans la suite de
la discussion générale
la parole est un monsieur robert
tropéano
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues longtemps considérée
comme la bière assad non la guerre
d'algérie ne doit pas rester la guerre
ça bug
nous avons suffisamment de recul
reconnaître que ce conflit d'une grande
violence physique psychologique et
symbolique s'est déroulée entre 1954 et
même si personne n'ignore les drames les
attentats et autres règlements de
comptes qui ont suivi le cessez le feu
issu des accords des liens sans plus
tarder vous l'avez souligné monsieur le
rapporteur
il faut apporter une réponse à ceux qui
ont répondu à l'âge de verdad à l'appel
de la nation avec abnégation et courage
je fus de cela pendant 28 mois oui il
est temps de créer les conditions d'un
rassemblement serait limité pour les
deux millions de jeunes soldats envoyés
de l'autre côté de la méditerranée et
bien sûr pour toutes les victimes
civiles assassinés à vagues et a pris le
19 mars 1962 pour tous ceux qui de la
poussée langlade au massacre d'oran ont
payé de leur vie l'indépendance
algérienne ou tout simplement pour
servir la fraise
il ne s'agit pas de refaire l'histoire
il s'agit de la regarder en face
aussi sans hésiter prenons toutes nos
responsabilités pour installer un devoir
de mémoire à la hauteur des sacrifices
endurés par beaucoup de nos concitoyens
car trop souvent sur cette question les
tergiversations l'ont emporté malgré
l'action déterminée des anciens de la
guerre d'algérie en particulier des
anciens combattants d'afrique du nord
j'étais toujours de ce combat contre
l'oubli
j'ai toujours soutenu sans faille toutes
les démarches qui visent à rétablir la
vérité historique et à rendre hommage à
toutes les victimes
je dis bien à toutes les victimes je
regrette sincèrement que la
représentation nationale ne puissent
s'unir
et se retrouver sur la date du 19 mars
1962 qui marque l'arrêt officiel des
hostilités et qui n'occulte en aucun cas
les événements tragiques postérieure à
celle ci cette date a du sens et c'est
indispensable pour donner vie à une
journée du souvenir et du recueillement
que nous souhaitons tous je regrette
aussi après tant d'années que ce soit
toujours un long processus
quand il s'agit d'oeuvrer en faveur
d'une lecture objective de la guerre
d'algérie en effet comme vous le savez
mes chers collègues il a fallu atteindre
37 ans pour que les opérations
effectuées en afrique du nord se
qualifier sur une vraie nature
la loi du 18 octobre 1999 remplacer une
formulation renault va clairement du
déni par celles plus tristes de guerre
d'algérie entièrement la loi du 9
décembre 1974 attribué à la qualité de
combattant aux personnes ayant participé
à ce conflit avait également été adoptée
à l'issue d'une course d'obstacles
subtilement mise à l'heure à l'époque
par les gouvernements successifs à cet
égard le débat du 17 octobre 1974 au
sénat et éclairage
le rapporteur de la loi du 9 décembre
lucienne grade membres de lagos
démocratiques s'expriment et ici vous
trouverez mes chers collègues d'amour
rapport la narration fidèle des langues
vicissitudes de ce projet de loi
nos espérances déçues à plusieurs
reprises au fil des années pour des
motifs divers mais toujours renouvelé
aujourd'hui il nous est permis de
discuter un projet de loi qui répondent
aux espoirs que nous entretenons depuis
12 heures reprenant les termes de
certains ici lé sénateur je dirais qu'il
nous est enfin permis de discuter
aujourd'hui une proposition de loi qui
répondent aux espoirs lever à nouveau il
y à vizag en effet en 2002 à
l'initiative de plusieurs familles
politiques parmi lesquels les radicaux
de gauche
l'assemblée nationale avait déjà adopté
une proposition de loi vise à
reconnaître le 19 mars
comme journée nationale du souvenir et
du recueillement à la mémoire des
victimes civiles et militaires de la
guerre d'algérie et des combats du maroc
et de tunisie depuis dix ans se sont
écoulés
le texte est resté volontairement
anglais dans les limbes d'une navette
parlementaire suspendue par le times qui
respecte bien hélas la difficile
réconciliation nationale sur la question
de la guerre d'algérie ainsi que je n'ai
déjà évoquée à l'effet du cirque oled
les plaies de cette tragédie sont encore
très vives
on peut le comprendre au regard des
milliers de civils et militaires
victimes de ce terrible déchirement
entre l'algérie et la france
la guerre d'algérie et passionnel à
cause de la cécité politique sur le
système colonial et sur l'inévitable
processus de décolonisation la guerre
d'algérie est forte de culpabilité en
raison de la torture assumée par
certains officiers comme moyenne de
lutte obligé contre le terrorisme la
guerre d'algérie est pleine de monde à
cause d art y abandonner au massacre
punitive de lendemain de guerre
en fait la guerre d'algérie empreinte de
douleur parce qu'elle a forcé à l'exode
des milliers de rapatrier pour qui
l'algérie était aussi leurs terres et
parce que les plus en trente ans les
plus hautes autorités leur avec une
promesse
l'algérie c'est la france dans son
dernier livre l'historien benjamin stora
rappelle que la mémoire des jeunes n'est
pas celle des autres
c'est vrai que l'histoire ne semble pas
la même selon que l'on est et soldats
rapatriés ou arty mais la somme de tous
ces souvenirs individuel rassemblés par
un dénominateur commun la douleur et
l'incompréhension doit naturellement
conduire à partager une même moment de
recueillement
c'est ici que se voit les choses et pour
ma part et pour celle de la majorité des
membres du groupe rdse
le choix du 19 mars est la date
symbolique la plus significative notre
collègue rapporteur nous a livré les
bons arguments
je ne vais pas tout vous les rappeler
mais j'insiste aurait un seul mâle sur
la nécessité de sang
date qui répondent à la même logique que
celle décidée pour raviver le souvenir
de la première et de la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est une question de clarté
pour les générations futures
c'est une question de sens à donner pour
cette journée de mémoire nous défaire
les victoires le cessez le feu du 19
mars 1962 doit être compris d'abord et
avant tout comme la promesse d'une paix
retrouvée
des deux côtés de la méditerranée
j'espère que le sénat
par ce vote contribuera à consolider une
mémoire collective cohérente et apaisée
comme il l'a fait à vandières
grâce à l'adoption de la proposition de
loi tendant à la reconnaissance de la
répression de la manifestation du 17
octobre 1961
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean vincent
placé
non
monsieur le président messieurs ministre
mes chers collègues
chers amis l'assistance je salue 50 ans
ça fait cinquante ans que la guerre
d'algérie est officiellement terminée un
demi siècle
et c'est bien connu souvent la mémoire
s'efface à ne jurent que les années
passent ne pas oublier je crois que
c'est là tout l'enjeu de notre débat
aujourd'hui au groupe écologiste nous
avons estimé qu'il fallait prendre le
temps de débattre sereinement de cette
proposition de loi et n'ont pas voté
dans l'urgence et je tiens à saluer à
cet égard le travail remarquable du
rapporteur à la mairie et son patient sa
passion sur le sujet et sa volonté des
coûts de l'ensemble des groupes et aussi
de convictions personnelles et de
discussions et de débats qui honore je
crois notre haute assemblée ça a été une
sage décision de discuter car chacun a
le temps de s'interroger sur ce sujet
complexe et de mûrir sa propre réflexion
nous poussons là un domaine délicat
celui du souvenir et cela ne peut
appartenir qu'à chacun avec son vécu son
ressenti son parcours personnel son
histoire et sa culture la mémoire et
qu'inévitablement pluriel et hétérogène
selon les rôles et les points de vue des
uns et des autres c'est pourquoi je
distingue la mémoire de l'histoire
tandis que la mémoire relève souvent de
la passion l'histoire appartient
davantage à la raison l'histoire c'est
le résultat d'une recherche méthodique
et savante qui a une vocation
pédagogique celle d' éduquer à la
citoyenneté notamment
il existe des faits historiques des
dates objectives comme celle du 19 mars
1961 ce jour 62 pardon bien sûr ce jour
où grâce aux accords d'evian
la france et le gouvernement provisoire
de la république algérienne ont décidé
le cessez le feu le 8 avril 62 une très
grande majorité des français 92 7% ont
d'ailleurs ratifié ces accords
certes ce n'est pas la fin de tous les
combats et des souffrances mais c'est un
symbole fort ancré dans la réalité
historique
les harkis les français les algériens
n'ont pas du tout bien sûr vécu cette
date de la même manière mais ils ont
tous été concernés par cette décision
et c'est au nom de ce passé commun que
le 19 mars 1962 fait sens c'est une
pierre de plus que l'on apporte à
l'édifice de la réconciliation
cette date malgré la discussion qui
l'entouré l'objet d'un consensus assez
large l'institutionnaliser permettrait
de dépasser les clivages pour aller vers
la commémoration de collectifs des
souffrances des victimes d'une tragédie
dont tout le monde a souffert les
victimes trop nombreuses
c'est à elle que nous devons ce vote
bien qu'aucun bilan chiffré ne puisse
être complètement vérifier avant le
cessez le feu
on ne comptait pas moins de 24 mille
deux cent soixante sept militaires
français tués sans compter les 65 mille
blessés 2780 habitués 7541 blessés 8 175
disparus civils français entre 30000 et
158 harkis tués ou disparus
et c'est vrai que là la vérité
historique est complexe à déterminer
qu'on peut voir l'écart de ce que sont
les statistiques au moins 141 miss d'art
de l'armée de libération nationale
algérienne et près de 300 milles à 400
mille algériens des cv ce bilan
dramatiquement lourds est encore très
certainement sous-estimé le parlement a
reconnu la responsabilité de la france
dans ce qu'il a lui-même requalifier de
guerre je crois qu'avec cette
proposition de loi
nous ne faisons que et c'est bien utile
parachever cette reconnaissance
officielle afin que l'on n'oublie pas
même si les années passent les victimes
des combats d'afrique du nord cela dit
et là j'interpelle bien sûr la
représentation parlementaire gardons
nous bien gardons nous bien besoin un
rôle qui n'est pas le nôtre d'une scène
de législateurs pas des historiens ni
des six
nous n'avons pas la légitimité de dire
quelle est la vérité qui sont les bons
ou les mauvais s'il y en avait en tant
que représentants nationaux
nous avons le devoir d'agir dans
l'intérêt commun est d'être responsable
à chacun de se recueillir et de se
remémorer les événements selon son vécu
à chaque historiens de poursuivre la
recherche vers la vérité historique pour
les élus que nous sommes
il s'agit simplement modestement de
reconnaître officiellement une journée
du souvenir qui permettent un travail
pédagogique car c'est aussi dans la
connaissance de son passé qu'on prépare
un meilleur avenir pour conclure ce
serait simplement rappelé qu'il n'y a
pas de vérité absolue dans ce domaine
comme dans beaucoup d'autres il n'existe
pas de date parfaite il n'en existera
jamais à mesure d'ailleurs que l'on se
crispe sur un jour on oublie l'essentiel
être ensemble pour commémorer les
victimes et les erreurs à ne plus
commettre
et c'est dans cette pensée sincère et
profonde que tout en respectant la vie d
un et deux autres dans cette haute
assemblée où le débat est extrêmement
digne jeu retrait comme la presque
unanimité du groupe écologiste pour la
proposition de loi présentée aujourd'hui
en masse qui vend d'ailleurs dans la
continuité de vote de mes camarades
écologistes à l'assemblée nationale en
noël mamère et marié nobert également
qui était co signataire avec bernard
charles
le président du groupe radical de
l'époque de la proposition de loi
relative à la reconnaissance du 19 mars
comme journée nationale du souvenir et
du recueillement à la mémoire des
victimes civiles et militaires de la
guerre d'algérie des combats du maroc et
de la tunisie
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
dans là dessus de discussion générale la
parole est un monsieur marc pillas th
le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous sommes curieusement appelés à nous
prononcer aujourd'hui à la demande du
groupe socialiste sur une proposition de
loi adoptée à l'assemblée nationale le
29 janvier 2002 il ya mes chers
collègues plus de dix ans le procédé est
étrange
il ne doit pas comporter beaucoup de
précédents on peut s'interroger
d'ailleurs sur la pertinence de cette
opération qui tient pas compte de
l'évolution des esprits et des textes
sur dix ans on peut aussi s'interroger
sur sa correction au plan de l'éthique
parlementaire
la demande de reconnaissance de la date
du 19 mars comme journée nationale du
souvenir et du recueillement à la
mémoire des victimes civiles et
militaires de la guerre d'algérie et des
combats en tunisie au maroc ravive un
vieux débat qui divise depuis toujours
et basse le monde des anciens
combattants et qui concerne bien entendu
au premier chef la communauté de nos
compatriotes rapatriés d'afrique du nord
vous avez déclaré monsieur le rapporteur
que le 19 mars doit apaiser rassemblés
en permettant de se souvenir de tous les
morts avant et après cette date comme on
le fait le 11 novembre et le 8 mai pour
les deux guerres mondiales
je trouve que votre procédés oratoires
est étonnant car vous dites vouloir
faire une chose rassembler et vous
proposer des dispositions qui
aboutissent au contraire vous savez
pourtant que le monde combattant reste
particulièrement divisée sur cette
question
vous avez dû recevoir comme moi
d'innombrables protestation contre votre
initiative dont celle du comité
d'entente des associations patriotiques
qui regroupe 40 associations d'anciens
combattants
un million deux cent mille membres et
celle des associations bien sûr de
rapatrier des harkis et de disparus le
mouvement d'indignation que soulève
initiative de votre groupe au sénat
démontre bien que loin de rassembler
elle règne elle ranime division les
souvenirs les passions opposé
croyez-vous que c'était le moment n'avez
vous pas remarqué que les oppositions
s'estomper peu à peu que les
associations d'anciens combattants sauf
une s'était rallié au projet de loi
fixant au 11 novembre la commémoration
de tous les morts pour la france que
j'ai eu l'honneur de rapporter au sénat
quand statu quo de raison c'était
s'était instaurée entre ceux qui
voulaient commémorer le 19 mars et ceux
qui avaient adopté la date du 5 décembre
je regrette que les auteurs de la
proposition de loi en débat n'ait pas eu
la sagesse de l'un d'entre eux alors
secrétaire d'état du gouvernement de
jospin de lionel jospin puis sur cette
problématique 19 mars déclaré lee
simmons à la tribune du sénat le 1er
décembre 2001 en réalité je vais citer
pardonnez moi
en réalité le domaine et plus
qu'historique il touche au plus profond
de nous-mêmes de notre histoire de
l'histoire de la france de l'histoire
des françaises les français et c'est
bien pour cela que sénateurs et députés
sont chargés de dire leurs mots des
textes ont été déposés sur lesquels il
faut réfléchir et ouvrir un vrai débat
mais sur un sujet comme celui-ci on ne
peut décider par une simple majorité
politique ou politicienne
que signifierait une décision prise à 51
% des votants
les uns et les autres disait monsieur le
floch
nous avons avancé les arguments
nécessaires et savons qu'il ya des
moments historiques
mais ces derniers sont ils suffisamment
fort pour nous imposer une date
tirant les conclusions d'un accord à
l'époque insurmontable le secrétaire
d'état jacques le floch ne persiste à
pas dans son intention première de
présenter ce projet de loi au sénat
déjà en 1981 29 associations sur trente
et une consultés par le ministre alors
en charge du dossier s'était opposé au
choix du 19 mars comme date d'une
quelconque commémoration je fais aussi
la position de valéry giscard d'estaing
de jacques chirac le nicolas sarkozy
mais aussi mes chers collègues de la
majorité de françois mitterrand
eh oui chers collègues françois françois
mitterrand tu déclaré lors d'une
conférence de presse donnée à l'elysée
le 24 septembre katona écoutez bien
s'ils sargis il s'agit de marquer le
recueillement et d'honorer les victimes
de la guerre d'algérie
je dis que cela ne peut pas être le 19
mars
et il ajoutait c'est une date doit être
officialisée pour célébrer le souvenir
des victimes de la guerre d'algérie
cela ne peut être le 19 mars car il y
aura confusion dans la mémoire de notre
peuple
ce n'est pas l'acte diplomatiques
rendues nécessaires à l'époque qui peut
s'identifier à ce qui pourrait
apparaître comme un grand moment de
notre histoire
d'autant plus que la guerre a continué
que d'autres victimes ont été comptés et
qu'au surplus il convient de le froisser
la conscience de personnes
voilà deux sages paroles m'arrive
rarement de citer le président
mitterrand mais des paroles oubliées
quant à lui de l'opposition a plaisir à
vous rappeler tous les présidents de la
vème république
le charles de gaulle à sarkozy y compris
françois mitterrand se sont opposés soit
officiellement soit en se taisant à la
commémoration officielle du 19 mars
vous avez bien compris ça nous a pas
échappé que bien qu ancien combattant
d'algérie moi même je suis très opposé
au texte en discussion
et ce pour des raisons de fond de forme
et d'opportunités la première raison de
fond la plus importante pour moi c'est
que votre initiative chers collègues de
la majorité ressuscite des divisions qui
avaient tendance à s'estomper au sein du
monde combattant ait ravivé les plaies
de tous ceux qui ont perdu des enfants
des parents des amis ou qui ont tout
perdu après le 19 mars
le 19 mars vous l'avez reconnu n'a pas
eu ce clip so facto entraîné la paix en
algérie
en effet les hostilités ne se sont pas
arrêtés le 19 mars 62 à partir de cette
date
et tout au long de l'année 62 malgré les
stipulations des accords d'evian
garantissant le respect des anciens
combattants d'origine algérienne
notamment ayant servi sous notre drapeau
drapeau français près de 150000 de ceux
ci furent exécutés dans des conditions
atroces il n'est pas les mauvais d'un
côté et les anges de l'autre et s'ils ne
furent que 60000 comme le prétend
d'autres sources
ils furent 60002 trop exécutés après
l'armistice
alors que nous respections nous les
accord engageant notre pays au cours de
cette même période postérieure au 19
mars 62 l'armée française vu 150 de tuer
4 122 blessés
cent soixante deux disparus ce n'était
donc pas la fin de la guerre
ce n'était pas la paix et que dire de
nos compatriotes civils disparus à
jamais près de 2000
que dire des massacres d'oran évoqué
tout à l'heure le 5 juillet 62 avec
leurs 4 156 morts ou disparus
non le 19 mars n'a pas ramené la paix en
algérie
ce serait contraire en le prétendant à
la vérité historique
la deuxième raison pour laquelle je me
pose à ce texte très à la patrie à la
tradition la france ne célèbre que les
victoires ou les actes exceptionnelle de
bravoure célébrant nous le 22 le 22 juin
1940 date de la signature par le
maréchal pétain de l'armistice
consacrant la défaite de la france
célébrons célébrant nous le 21 juillet
50,4 date de la signature des accords de
genève met enfin la guerre d'indochine
et par là même à la présence française
en indochine
non nous célébrons avec ferveur le 8 mai
date de la victoire sur l'allemagne
nazie et le 11 et le 11 novembre
nul n'est parfait et le 11 novembre date
de la victoire de la première guerre
mondiale
la troisième raison ma troisième raison
tient à la décence
nous devons imaginer l'épreuve moral que
représente pour les anciens d'algérie
ans
tout cas pour beaucoup d'entre eux le
fait de célébrer le souvenir de leurs
morts
le même jour que l'algérie indépendante
et c'est bien son droit fait sa victoire
le 19 mars est devenu en algérie la fête
de la victoire pour les anciens
d'algérie pour les anciens rapatrie les
rapatrier pour nos anciens compatriotes
il est particulièrement inacceptable
compte tenu du nombre de morts survenus
postérieurement au 19 mars et notamment
chez nos amis a requis de célébrer quoi
que ce soit en ce jour anniversaire
choisir la date du 19 mars est aussi
ravivé les pires souvenirs de tous ceux
militaires du contingent dont j'étais et
professionnels qui séjournent en algérie
après cette date on poste ont constaté
impuissant toutes les exactions commises
par le fln et les malheurs frappant la
population tant européenne que
maghrébine je ne veux pas croire que
l'inscription de ce texte à l'ordre à
notre ordre du jour soient destinées à
donner des gages à l'état algérien à
quelques jours du voyage de monsieur
hollande à alger qui était qui était qui
était d'ailleurs monsieur hollande était
d'ailleurs vous vous faites de la
politique j'en fais un petit peu
pardonnez moi il était d'ailleurs
signataire qui était signataire avec
vous monsieur le rapporteur de la
proposition de loi en débat
cette proposition est d'ailleurs
contradictoire avec l'existence de la
journée commémorative du 5 décembre
instaurée après concertation par un
décret du 26 septembre 2003 envoyées en
temps d écouter en plus en outre la loi
du 23 février 2005 portant
reconnaissance par la nation et
contribution nationale en faveur des
français rapatriés indique que la nation
associe les rapatriés d'afrique du nord
les personnes disparues et les
populations civiles victimes de
massacres ou d'exactions commises durant
la guerre d'algérie après 19 matches en
violation des accords d'evian
à l'hommage rendu je ne suis pas le seul
à l'hommage rendu le 5 décembre
combattants morts pour la france en
afrique du nord et surtout mes chers
collègues
souvenons nous en nous avons voté le 28
février dernier à la quasi unanimité et
vous avez pris par monsieur le
rapporteur à la loi dite du 11-novembre
fixant à ce jeu le fixant à cette date
la commémoration de tous les morts pour
la france
texte qui stipule expressément et c'est
votre amendement monsieur eric que j'ai
accepté que cet hommage ne se substitue
pas aux autres journée de commémoration
nationale
vous vous en souvenez monsieur le
rapporteur et voyez je rend à césar ce
qui est à césar c'est à votre demande
que cette précision a été apportée avec
l'accord du ministre à la célébration du
19 mars
porté par deux associations est donc
protégé comme l'est celle du 5 décembre
porté par les autres associations
représentatives du gong du monde
combattant chacun conservant ainsi le
libre choix de la date de commémoration
qui préfèrent votre texte du cher
collègue et donc superfétatoire et
inutile
ce n'est pas le moindre de ses défauts
le plus important à mes yeux étant et
tente de jeter de l'huile sur le feu
alors que nous allions vers un
apaisement des passions marquée par
l'approbation quasi unanime de cette loi
et que les anciens combattants
s'habituait avec le temps à ces
célébrations à des dates différentes de
la faim juridique
j'ai constaté un dépassement de quatre
minutes tout à l'heure alors c'est vous
alors si vous permettez il convenait je
crois de laisser du temps au temps
que pensent nos querelles des arrières
petits enfants des anciens d'algérie jeu
ecoutez-moi deux minutes une minute
son concert collègues je conclus je ne
prétends pas que les uns ont raison et
que les autres en tort il ne donne pas
au 19 mars la même signification pour
les uns c'est de retour en métropole à
la maison pour les autres et notamment
pour nos compatriotes d'algérie pour les
familles des harkis massacrés des
disparus un jour de deuil de grande
tristesse de grande tristesse que nous
devons respecter le respect que nous
leur devons celui que nous devons à ceux
qui sont morts
les faisant leur devoir devrait nous
conduire à contribuer à l'apaisement des
conflits et les passions pour l'ensemble
de ces raisons le groupe des sénateurs
ump ne votera pas ce texte je m'adresse
pour terminer à monsieur le ministre
monsieur milices comme vos prédécesseurs
vous adopter une position de rsa bleus
de rassemblement en appelant à un vote
de sagesse du sénat et je vous en
remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole comme
monsieur georges labazée
c'est le président le service mais chers
collègues
aujourd'hui cinquante ans après la
signature des accords d'evian il est
temps pour la france de regarder son
histoire en face et de permettre au
travail de mémoire de s'effectuer avec
rigueur et sérénité l'instauration d'une
journée de souvenir du conflit et de ses
victimes répond à ce souci de
clarification et d'apaisement
cette journée nationale permettra aussi
de tirer les enseignements du passé
cet acte de mémoire nous le devons
surtout aux générations futures
aujourd'hui les jeunes générations en
france comme en algérie manifeste avec
force un besoin de paix de vérité et de
justice victime question de l'histoire
coloniale occulter ici ou d'une guerre
d'indépendance mythifié là bas une telle
reconnaissance devrait aussi mettre un
terme aux polémiques mémorielle de
l'algérie et nous permettre de renforcer
notre amitié
notre partenariat avec le maroc la
tunisie ceneri vos chers collègues je
vais vous citer le 22 janvier 2002 à
l'assemblée nationale vous déclariez
cette guerre qui fut trop longtemps une
guerre sans nom ne doit pas devenir une
guerre sans date pour se recueillir et
se souvenir qu'elle date permettrait au
monde combattant aux familles de
rapatrier aux citoyens de toutes
générations de communier dans le même
souvenir et de préparer l'avenir
le 19 mars jour de l'application du
cessez le feu
s'impose à l'évidence comme l'unique
date capable de symboliser
les conflits d'afrique du nord celle ci
s'inscrit par ailleurs dans la tradition
républicaine de souvenirs qui fait du
jour du cessez le feu
le jour commémoratif d'un conflit au
même titre que les deux conflits
mondiaux de la guerre d'algérie a droit
elle aussi à une journée de mémoire la
tradition républicaine le cra date
retenue soit celle de la cessation
officiel des combats
à défaut de la fin de la guerre pour la
guerre d'algérie le 19 mars date du
cessez le feu
même si ce ne fut pas la fin de la
guerre s'impose comme faisant suite aux
accords d'evian
cette décision historique cela a été
rappelé fut ratifiée par le référendum
du 8 avril 62 à l'écrasante majorité en
faveur de la paix et du droit des
algériennes à l'autodétermination
ainsi le 19 mars le signe une victoire
nîmes défaite militaire
les une démarche politique salutaire et
largement approuvé le 19 mars apparaît
bien comme la date qui a le plus de sens
et de légitimité
c'est aussi un choix responsable
l'ambition de la présente proposition de
loi est de parachever le mouvement de
reconnaissance officielle de la guerre
d'algérie et des combats en tunisie au
maroc afin d'encourager la
réconciliation nationale et la recherche
de la vérité historique dans un but
pédagogique
à la lumière des valeurs républicaines
et humanistes sur lesquels s'appuient
notre constitution je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue chers collègues
compte tenu de la reprise à sion c'est
15 heures précises cet après midi je
suis obligé de suspendre science la
suite de l'examen de cette proposition
de loi est prévu confirmant la
conférence des présidents le mardi 20
novembre à 14h30
voilà pour la discussion générale de
cette proposition de loi pour revoir ce
débat notre site internet publicsenat.fr
bonne journée à tous